gold rush has been on the air for over a
decade and cast members have come and
gone would you believe teenagers had
outclassed miners three times their age
you're the most successful gold rush
characters ranked
former army medic fred lewis first
appeared on parker schnabel's spin-off
series gold rush parker's trail he was
hired to replace schnabel's former
operator rick ness on a dangerous
expedition into papua new guinea he
joined the main show in season 11 as he
and his rookie team sought to take
advantage of the record high prices of
gold and record low prices of oil
brought on by the kovan 19 pandemic
we're not just looking to have a good
season i want to make the lewis
family name in the madden family name
well known despite being an impressively
bearded and patriotic group of would-be
miners lewis and his crew lacked the
aptitude and ability to learn skills
that would save their season even a
visit from series fixer freddie dodge
wasn't able to get team lewis back on
track
in the end the lewis crew's total yield
was just 6.4 ounces with a worth of
about 11 400 the team earned less than
half of what the hoffman crew mined in
their first season despite his failures
lewis has returned for season 12 as well
as the 2021 limited series gold rush
winter's fortune will his luck improve
with experience only time will tell
veteran minor and quarry expert dave
turin was brought in in season one to
assist his friend todd hoffman's
fledgling attempts at finding gold for
three years he assisted the hoffman crew
and was integral to their continued
success after hoffman's ill-fated
expedition into guyana in season 4 turin
ended their partnership and teamed up
with freddie dodge on a new mining
operation in the klondike in season 5
hoffman convinced turin to rejoin his
crew in exchange for a 50 ownership
stake in hoffman's new claim in 2019 he
starred in the gold rush spin-off dave
turin's lost minds traveling across the
country and rehabilitating abandoned
gold mines
since he was never a crew leader on gold
rush his gold yields were not tallied
however the hard work he completed with
the hoffman crew and the fact that he
extended the gold rush franchise with
his own spin-off earns him a place on
this list
when miners are in trouble they call
freddy dodge much like his colleague
dave turin dodge was on hand to assist
the hoffman crew in its first two
seasons before joining them full time in
season three after leaving hoffman
behind in guyana to work a klondike
claim with his brother dodge returned to
the hoffman crew in season 5 and has
appeared off and on ever since he's
often called to assist in particularly
dire moments such as rick ness's
collapsing wash plant in season 9 or
fred lewis's failing crew in season 11.
in 2021 dodge hosted the six episode
special freddie dodge's mine rescue
visiting underperforming gold mines
across the country and getting them back
on track
lots of gold in this country the old
timers hit it pretty hard you know they
found lots of large nuggets
like dave turin dodge's gold yields on
the show have not been tallied however
his trusted place within every crew he
works with along with his success as an
ambassador of the gold rush brand earns
him a place among the show's most
successful cast members
miners fred hurt and his son dustin
better known as the dakota boys were
introduced in season one they became
regular cast members in season two and
they leased the porcupine creek mine out
from under todd hoffman after he missed
a lease payment free to mine the claim
as they please the dakota boys attempted
to reach the glory hole a gold rich
deposit at the bottom of a water-filled
ravine which jack hoffman had previously
gone after the work on the glory hole
was beset with problems from a decaying
cabin on their dig site to the threat of
major flooding due to melting snow caps
on a nearby mountain the dakota boys
spent three seasons on gold rush before
setting out on multiple spin-off series
all that glitters then gold rush white
water in their time on the original
series they yielded 523 ounces of gold
in total worth over 930 thousand dollars
in season four they achieved a personal
best yield of 280 ounces
in recent years fred has taken some time
away from white water leaving dustin to
carry on the family business and the
dakota name
rick ness spent a long time as parker
schnabel's operator in foreman before
striking out on his own in season 9.
after todd hoffman left the show ness
took his position as the third leg of
gold rush's three-team structure known
for his tattoos and sleeveless shirts
ness's time on the show has been marked
with struggle he learned on the job that
being a skilled foreman is not the same
thing as being a skilled crew leader i'm
the boss it's 100 my operation
i've never had this much responsibility
before i've never put you know my own
money on the line like this
nasa's had to deal with low yields and
debt as well as his team's low morale as
he works to improve his performance this
has shown he can be a responsible
decision maker and even brought freddie
dodge in to help ride his operation and
fix some equipment however he does make
some more reckless calls as well such as
reopening a plot of land as winter set
in at the end of season 10. in his three
seasons as crew leader nessus yielded a
total of 2
732 ounces worth about 4.8 million
dollars
his first season yield of 1 100 ounces
remains his personal best
if you revisit the early seasons of gold
rush you'll notice a significant amount
of screen time is dedicated to todd
hoffman's inexperience and failure after
his oregon-based aviation business went
under hoffman gathered a team of other
unemployed men his father jack and a
camera crew before setting out for
alaska he had a considerable amount of
faith in himself and a showman's
instinct for good tv however he lacked
even basic gold mining experience his
first mining season ended with a yield
of just under 15 ounces but hoffman was
undeterred
we haven't accomplished our goal we've
proven that you can still do stuff like
this here in america over the course of
the next two seasons he and his team
improved greatly then came a disastrous
trip to guyana in season 4 where hoffman
and his crew were utterly defeated by
the south american jungle mining just
two ounces of gold before an
unsuccessful pivot to diamond mining
after returning to the yukon in season 5
hoffman's skill and attitude recovered
in season six he mined a personal best
3032 ounces after failed attempts to
open minds in colorado and his home
state of oregon hoffman left gold rush
in the mining industry altogether after
season eight he would finish the series
with a total yield of 8039 ounces of
gold worth 14.3 million dollars
colorful dutch miner tony beatz first
appeared on the show in season 2 when
the hoffman crew relocated to dawson
city yukon before long he became a fan
favorite with his wild beard and foul
mouth demeanor he was seemingly made to
become a breakout reality tv star it
helped that he was by far the most
experienced minor of the show's main
cast for tony this is a bad week 220
ounces of gold worth about 350 thousand
dollars
his brusque way of doing business has
also earned him long-standing beasts
with co-stars rick ness and parker
schnabel starting out in season five
with an ambitious quest to get a 75 year
old dredge mine up and running beats has
been running his cruise with the
assistance of his wife minnie and his
daughter monica like the hoffman crew
his seasons have been up and down
however thanks to his prior experience
in the industry when beats has a good
season he brings in a lot of gold to
date beats his mind a total of 16 261
ounces of gold were 28.9 million dollars
in season seven he managed the largest
single gold cleanup in the show's
history to that point but his personal
best came in season 9 with 4 400 ounces
beets would be the most consistently
successful miner on the show if not for
the last name on this list
when it comes to gold yields parker
schnabel is head and shoulders above the
rest schnabel joined the gold rush cast
as a teenager working on one of his
grandfather's old claims throughout his
career on the show schnabel has mined an
incredible 39 910 ounces or 67.8 million
dollars
not only has schnabel found success as a
minor he is also the longest-running
most consistent star of gold rush
starting as a 16 year old overcharging
the hoffman crew for firewood schnabel
emerged as not just a camera friendly
presence but a mining prodigy who saved
the hoffman crew from their own
incompetence on more than one occasion
inspired by his grandfather john a
lifelong alaskan miner schnabel
excavated the big nugget creek mine on
his own in season 2. while that claim
yielded just 34 ounces he very quickly
moved on to bigger and better things
since season 4 he has been the top
earner of each season yielding a record
7509 ounces in season 11. through the
years he has faced setbacks and
hardships including the death of his
grandfather but has managed to persevere
and thrive both in the mountains and on
camera
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
gold rush are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]